les chantiers de toutes parts sont en
cours dans la zac chars renard de saint
cyr l'école de nombreux immeubles sont
érigés dans cette ancienne zone
militaire afin de construire un nouvel
écoquartier c'est un écoquartier en
effet avec une zone 30 surtout tout le
quartier
donc une zone partagée entre les piétons
les vélos et les voitures on a été
extrêmement pugnaces sur le nombre de
parkings dans les bâtiments justement
pour éviter les voitures en surface
l'objectif oui c'est des noues des
espaces de prairies est vraiment un
sentiment de vivre à la fois la ville à
la fois la campagne plusieurs grosses
infrastructures vont ils voir le jour
parmi elles le pôle sportif pierre
mazeaud 6000 mètres carrés sur trois
étages soit trois fois plus grand qu'un
gymnase classique de nombreuses salles
pourront recevoir des activités diverses
de la gymnastique aux sports de combat
axe principal du projet la salle
multisports de niveau régional étudié
pour accueillir à la fois un sport
d'intérieur et de l' escalade l'élément
phare vraiment c'est la structure
d'escaladé la structure artificielle
d'escaladé c'est quelque chose qu'on n'a
pas du tout sur la ville de saint cyr
actuellement donc ça c'est vraiment un
point fort
il ya beaucoup d'attentes au niveau de
la ville sur sur cet espace de pratique
à une petite centaine de mètres de là un
autre grand chantier celui de la maison
des associations la maison des
associations 1 fatal vient en
remplacement du centre ces marques
étaient l'ancien centre des associations
qui était composé d'une
d'une ancienne demeure de m et puis deux
bâtiments qui au fur et à mesure des
années avaient été rajoutés sauf que les
bâtiments n'étaient pas pmr
était vieillissant d'une manufacture
part pas très joyeuse voire même délabré
la maison des associations doit ouvrir à
partir du 15 septembre prochain
quant au pôle sportif pierre mazeaud
l'inauguration est prévue au moment du
forum des associations le 11 septembre
à noter que deux écoles sont également
en passe d'être achevés pour la rentrée
prochaine